and look at this too more wacky weather
in the golden state the los angeles area
saw lightning strikes yesterday it
actually caused beaches in the area to
shut down for a bit so this is where
they were in tandem with each other
right so you had those thunderstorms
those thunderstorms created that hail
you saw okay we had lightning strikes
here too so which is one of those crazy
systems it sure was do you think
filmmakers were just taking video of the
sky there during that lightning storm
because they're like at some point we
will use this in a future cinematic
release let's get this
[Laughter]
this is our second full moon okay
because the third one is going to be
tomorrow then it's over with and we
caught the snow moon for this time
during
the year according to the farmers
almanac top gusts today so of course we
had those big wins yesterday but this
morning still some leftover wins and we
knew that was going to happen north las
vegas closer to 40. read at 36 henderson
31 someone at 30 for our wind gusts so
another gusty day today temperatures
outside still rather cool 57 for
centennial hills 64 spring valley was so
nice last week with those 70s but now
we've cooled things off all across the
region 64 whitney ranch henderson 60 58
southern highlands 60 even for mountains
edge and again we'll switch up our
neighborhoods with our next weather cast
59 currently for boulder city 57 prep
laughlin coming in at 68 degrees so
there are weather alerts out there wind
advisories actually just not for us here
in las vegas but western clark up there
in indian springs all the way to nye
amargosa valley prompt for you this goes
in effect until nine o'clock as we could
still see gusts between 40 to 55 miles
per hour these are all coming from the
north okay that's because that low
that's spinning up towards the east
rotates all those northerly winds and
the cooler temperatures around that
that's what we're seeing outside right
now in fact look at that northeast clark
earlier today around the two o'clock
hour we actually picked up some
sprinkles up there right around mesquite
and the arizona corridor but now things
have cleared up rain chances go up a
little for next week look at that now
dwelling just a little bit less now but
chances are out there for monday we'll
see if it all changes as we get closer
to that event for next week wind
forecast though we do know that we're
going to get more wind tomorrow you'll
see the colors here also for your
thursday unfortunately still breezy
tomorrow but for friday for all those
plans you have doesn't look so bad
let's start to clear things up winds
start to calm down a little still some
north breezes though in those north
northeast neighborhoods like nellis
camino al norte and alliante 43 degrees
overnight breezy and chilly your gusts
up to 25 nothing like yesterday 62
tomorrow breezy and cool temperatures
will be right near normal here your
highs neighborhood by neighbor low 60s
here 58 for you and someone though 59
for anthem we'll be at 61 north las
vegas along with aliante outside the
valley here you go 58 for prim at state
line 60 for boulder city tomorrow
afternoon here is your eight day
forecast lots of sunshine temperatures
will warm up look at this for the
weekend yes just in time all right next
week though
as we cool things off again slight
chance of showers on monday next week
cooler 50s you'll need the jacket but
look at our weekend don't mess with our
weekend that's quite a range 70 to 56.
it's all over the place welcome to las
vegas welcome to town that's hockey
right so what are we about 40 minutes
from